quoi bien sûr on peut encore peut faire
deux choses
c'est leur calme je dirais qu'il est
violent et surtout dans la vie de tous
les jours
tiens d'ailleurs j'ai une question à
vous poser question philosophique quelle
est la chose pour vous la plus
importante dans la vie à 18h49 en direct
sur ces huit mois 1 je vais demander
guillaume genton on s'est mal s'habiller
annoncé les vêtements les vêtements pas
vous seriez ça reflète notre
personnalité et bah oui bah alors bon je
suis en dépression non franchement c'est
très très beau ce que voudrait l'animal
là les magnifiques
ouais maintenant les vendeurs ils ont
trouvé une nouvelle technique pour le
pigeonner c'est quoi faty organise des
faux événements maintenant
il m'a dit venez à ce que j'entends il
ya une soirée kanye west aussi basse et
chant mais je vais
je suis arrivée au magasin n'y avait
personne ils ont juste me le dise de
kanye west
c'est génial
c'est bien c'est quand on voulait sous
la plus importante la santé la santé
après brest fouet ballon face à santés
parce que la cerise le monde bah oui à
terme
d'échangés toujours renouer phalaris de
deux livres quoi c'est vrai moi la fois
j'avais un ongle incarné je n'ai pas
bien vu la journée comme ça te couches
foulèrent alors oui nouvelle raquette de
tennis j'avais vraiment des grosses
non mais vraiment c'est un truc de fou
voyez un peu les chaussures qui sont
dans cette équipe bernard montiel alors
jaillir la santé évidemment y avoir des
amis alors c'est comme vous avez raté
votre vie
[Applaudissements]
magri famille de la jeune fille des
années richard inaba ça vous aimez
danser à faire des amis tant qu'à faire
pour pouvoir les gratter non non non
mais si t'as qu'à rajouter ça c'est
géraldine qu'à rajouter ça non avoir des
amis franchement cercle d'amis vraiment
proches voilà que vous considérez pas
beaucoup sincèrement pas bois est ce que
moi vont considérer comme un ami non
[Applaudissements]
en foot et alors mais c'est vrai et je
suis content de ce moment il ne manque
pas d'oreilles à
quand vous êtes ami avec lui il faut
envoyer moi alors dit moi non des amis
proches n'ont rien a très très peu alors
j'ai des amis depuis depuis l'école
carrément depuis la fac et puis j'ai
quelques nouveaux amis que j'aime
profondément mais c'est difficile smith
existe parce qu'avec la vision nous
avons c'est difficile parce que vous
dire par exemple je ya des gens autour
de la table que je considère vraiment
comme des amis c'est bouleversant mais
vous me considérais comme un ami moi non
non rien aux problèmes déjà de 2 des cas
c'est le nom mais je vous aime beaucoup
je conseille au choix je vous dis y'a et
je le dis à personne que je considère
comme des amis à la peine alors oui
voilà valérie votre meilleur album here
i am ennemi ou c'est pas de deviner mais
alors
[Applaudissements]
je me suis mis dans la merde
je vais vous dire non en fait je viens
de raconter
de
l'habitat
je vais le dire je vais le dire sous
laquelle je sais quoi de plus important
pour vous dans la vie mais c'est bouger
ça prouve qu'il est encore vivante
arrêtez vous êtes modifier l'arrêté vous
bougez demandé au mieux vous lever la
jambe comme personne c'est vrai non mais
c'est vrai ça rigolait voulu et plus
rageant que l'uv auch l'élève son
physique
et pc voudrais vous dire des choses dont
on s'en fout maintenant je rigolais
c'est que de moins en moins de personnes
me le demande de lever la jambe
ah ouais non mais c'est vrai mais en
tout cas elle a un corps je vous jure
elle a des jambes isabelle j'ai rarement
vu des gens aussi belle n'a fait vrai
car je crois bien sûr fait le grand
écart et je peux vous dire que quelqu'un
qui fait le grand écart
c'est le règne en termes sexuelles
[Rires]
non mais j'en aime personnes et sous
j'ai un ami
j'ai un ami qui sortait avec une
gymnaste way d'ailleurs on l'appelle à
barres parallèles
mais je vous jure il a vécu des choses
incroyables s'appelle will s'appelle
yann qu'attend
[Applaudissements]
on l'appelle la petite poutres latérales
dans le monde y compris moi c'est très
simple savoir dire bonjour c'est très
important comme richard anconina dans
itinéraire d'un enfant gâté moi je vous
dis en bois
savoir dire bonjour et que les enfants
soient en bonne santé de
sa mère et mon père ont saisi pourra les
arrêter si vos enfants ils sont en
mauvaise santé ça vous tue votre vie
vous avez pu nous aimons n'est pas là
dedans on a dit pas la santé ce qui est
important oui et prostituées
[Applaudissements]
d'abord aussi c'est que la seule
personne qui passe des enfants aux
prostituées aussi vite
mais c'est pour déconner bien sûr c'est
pour déconner et puis voilà franchement
où la
prostituée voilà voilà voilà alors oui
voilà c'est dur de repartir oui moi ce
serait l'amour j'étais simplement vous
quoi l'amour passion parce que non non
non ni l'amour passion c'est pas l'amour
un homme une femme moi l'amour qui
m'intéressent ça ça m'intéresse plus ce
qui m'intéresse c'est pire que moi la
matière c'est l'amour socialos albert
aimer et être aimés on retrouve laquelle
tu t'adresses et de domaine ainsi que le
cas en séries tu es d'accord c'est ça
qui m'importe dans la vie si aimé et
excusez-moi lc bout de
son nez mais très méfiant le raid s'est
émue et très minéral
[Rires]
aujourd'hui je suis dans un adulte
elle est comme un
petit miss france car hélas pas la
guerre bat
aldi d'amitié parce que si brest on
n'avait plus rien et j'ai pu le vérifier
c'est vrai oui bah ouais mais c'est vrai
ça me fait peur il est toujours
accouchement non mais ça me fait plaisir
c'est facile à dire ce à quoi
par l'amitié
l'argent c'est plus important que vous
avez un coup tout l'argent sur la torah
[Rires]
au départ ils partent tous
au début c'est l'amitié la santé la
prudence est effectué
moi
[Applaudissements]
moi ce qui est important pour moi c'est
la spiritualité ses maîtres
j'ai vécu
[Rires]
deux essais en fait c'est pas
moi c'est pas deux choses ces deux
personnes le fils mon mec
c'est nul c nul à nice et vous qu'est ce
qu'ils font pour le
connais pas du tout non c'est quoi et
puis ne pas avoir pensé à l'argent pour
pouvoir gâter perso pour tout gâter
galerie dit la vérité intérieure un truc
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai
tout à l'heure j'ai demandé un vol chez
elle faisait souvent l'amour ouais à
quelle fréquence oui parce que j'aime
bien demander ça à tout le monde pour
savoir quand moi je suis au fait chez
tout le monde et ça s'est tellement il
se situe dans sa vie ouais almadies est
ce que tu crois vraiment que je vais te
réponds de petite conne et au final elle
m'a dit ne t'inquiète pas c'est je te le
dire un secret mais ne le disent surtout
à personne
un million car en tout cas merci et elle
m'a dit c'est matin et soir minimum
pas du tout ce que j'ai dit j'ai dit ne
t'inquiète pas ma chérie tu tout va bien
merci ça ça veut dire ça et on va bien
merci spam atari soit sait pas qu'elle a
mal au dos
aux rebelles de merde pour que tu veux
je crois qu'elle a déjà calé à la bague
au sis à me dire c'est moi non mais
c'est vrai déjà c'est très compliqué
pour elle la non mais c'est vrai donc
vous c'est quoi
on a un truc rock'n roll intra ça va
être un cadre à l'aller
mais en son chien c'est important c'est
c'est une belle épilation
non tout va partir en vacances
déchetterie des comme toi j'ai vécu des
cultes
oui et puis de cuda
[Applaudissements]
on
va arrêter de se mentir nous dans cette
émission ne m'ont plu oui une année on a
menti 2016
je m'en rappelle alors vous bleu
vous écoutez contraire le brief soigner
le plus officiel
mollo parce que l'ue va partir dans un
bailleur non non mais c'est vrai genre
il va nous dire ça y est j'ai beaucoup
réfléchi je vais être honnête
quelque chose qu'il n'a jamais quitté le
succès
on va pas dire n'importe quoi
aujourd'hui
crédit relais on repart on oublie ouf
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors en partie sur la patte cassée
choix d'antenne pas une déprogrammation
c'est vrai j'étais un petit peu grisé à
ça au succès qu'on est mené ou pas pour
être dans le succès d'accord vous l'avez
eue je les ai eu aussi à tout con à la
naissance et au tour précédent dans
quelle ville et les chiens c'est toi à
l'époque elle vit une eau de vie pas la
tienne non merci horrible de dire ça il
a eu un énorme succès alors oui c'était
la star d'énergie louise mercier une
émission de se fonder sur les berges de
100 kg
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai eu le loisir tu pourrais aussi
nombreux de refuser des émissions qui en
a besoin on peut le dire des bêtises et
sur les chats
[Rires]
l'émission s'appelle m
[Musique]
ok vous bande de racailles
des beaux-arts salut à tous bienvenue
dormi
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue à tous en direct dans la
nouvelle émission spéciale
excusez ce soir
qui se fait bousculer par une pelleteuse
s'est passé bien lire en fête et une
petite réunion qui avait des fêtes nrj12
et mehmedi y aura des chats autour de
toi sur le plateau dit j'aime pas les
chats way to me chantait spectateurs je
ne veux pas ça autour de moi j'aime pas
ça j'aime bien les chiens du coup de là
est née une altercation et tout ça j'ai
refusé de la science aaas j'ai refusé ce
métier pas mentir aux gens je ne serai
pas à béziers sur des chats j'aime pas
les chats non mais ce sont des chiens
tôt mais c'est incroyable à elle à
l'égard la sadc vos témoignages m'ont
dit c'est pas
le succès vraiment dire non pas oui eh
ben voilà j'ai fait dire qu'est ce que
c'est le succès aussi non ça va partir
[Applaudissements]